Hey, guys, by the way, Joe Biden's going to
be the next president.
There is a really big deal being made out
of a breaking story from investigative reporter
Carl Carl Bernstein of Woodward and Bernstein
fame, about 21 Republican senators who privately
have been saying anti Trump things.
And I am here to tell you, I do not care if
they don't say it publicly and they didn't
say it publicly for the last four years, who
cares that they were privately willing to
say it to Carl Bernstein?
You know, the there's a couple possibilities
here.
Either they weren't saying it publicly because
for a while they supported Trump or they weren't
saying it publicly because they thought that
it was better for their own careers to shut
their mouths.
Either way, their silence was terrible for
the country for the last four years.
But we'll come back to that.
OK, Carl Bernstein tweeted yesterday and dozens
of articles were written about this.
The 21 Republican senators who have privately
expressed their disdain for Trump are Portman,
Alexander, Sasse, Blunt, Collins, Murkowski,
Cornyn, Thune, Romney, Braun, Young, Tim Scott,
Rick Scott, Rubio, Grassley, Burr, Toomey,
McSally, Moran, Roberts and Shelby.
Of the people on Bernstein's list, some did
actually criticize Trump publicly, like Ben
Sasse, John Cornyn, occasionally Lisa Murkowski,
certainly Mitt Romney.
But I have to tell you, I'm finding myself
completely underwhelmed by this.
Donald Trump has represented an existential
threat to the American system of democracy
in government and way of life.
For four years, a couple of senators have
mildly criticized Donald Trump and even the
ones that did a little more harshly.
Mitt Romney, for example, you know, John Kasich,
within days of Joe Biden winning, they went
right back to saying, my goal is stopping
Medicare for all.
We've got to stop tax increases.
We've got to deal with the debt.
We have to, you know, reduce business regulation.
So if anyone expects me to praise Republican
senators who privately criticize Donald Trump,
give me a break, guys.
Imagine if from day one of this presidency
or six months and, you know, whenever it was
abundantly clear to everybody that this was
a disaster, imagine if early on.
Twenty one Republican senators had actually
stood up regularly and strongly criticizing
Donald Trump.
That actually could have made a difference.
Instead, now that Joe Biden has already won,
we hear, oh, twenty one of them said things
in private about Trump.
To Carl Bernstein, Give me a break.
These people are pathetic.
Now, one other aspect of this, Trump and Republicans
love to say it's the left that doesn't allow
dissenting opinions and it's the left that
doesn't want to engage in the battle of ideas.
These twenty one Republicans, if it is true
that they really didn't like what Donald Trump
was doing, they partially stayed quiet because
they were too scared to say anything.
They were afraid of being outed publicly as
not liking Donald Trump when Trump was still
riding high.
This is what we call profiles in cowardice.
They aided and abetted Trump.
And if indeed they felt this all along, they
have.
To be held accountable now for how Donald
Trump has debased democracy for four years
and I mean, think back to impeachment, guys,
everyone but Romney who did vote to convict
on one count on impeachment, if these other
20 Republican senators had voted to convict
Trump on impeachment, they'd have been able
to remove him and they wouldn't have had to
worry about the repercussions of coming out
against Donald Trump.
Truly pathetic.
None of these people should be held up as
heroes.
In fact, what they are is disingenuous, if
indeed nearly half of the Republican senators
in the Senate privately were disturbed, distraught
and against what Donald Trump was doing, what
they need to be sort of what the what we need
to be pointing the finger to is that they
were completely disingenuous in public and
continuing to support Donald Trump.
Completely pathetic.
I'm glad we learned about it.
These are not heroes.
These are not our friends.
And as we saw from Mitt Romney and John Kasich
within 24 hours of the election, they obviously
and predictably, as we've been saying for
years, went right back to the exact type of
Republicans they were before Donald Trump.